no one could have imagined what the next
year would have in store
[Music]
the nation experienced tragedy sorrow
and isolation as well as unbelievable
levels
of bravery determination and strength
[Applause]
the disease that tore us apart also
brought us together
as families friends neighbors and
strangers
faced an uncertain future
[Applause]
2020 will this year be remembered
as one to forget
2020 is upon us we have so much to look
forward to the summer olympics in
tokyo euro 2020 the final at wembley
together
folks let's make twenty twenty the start
of something special
[Music]
a mystery virus infects dozens of people
in wuhan
china the victims succumb to a
pneumonia-like
illness the disease would later be named
covert 19.
it is absolutely critical that public
health authorities
recognize a super spreading event
in the very earliest stages before it
goes
absolutely explosive
january 24th seven countries report
covert 19 infections including the
united states
there are 846 cases worldwide and 25
deaths
today will be the first cobra meeting to
discuss the new strain of coronavirus
boris johnson doesn't go are the chinese
sharing all the information we need
we'll be we're going into cobra now and
we'll be making a statement afterwards
the who warned world leaders to stay on
alert
make no mistake this is
though an emergency in china
but it has not yet become
a global health emergency it may
yet become one
the virus would have a chance to spread
as families traveled for the lunar new
year holiday and foreign nationals
returned to their home countries
obviously we're doing everything
we can to ensure that people come to who
do come to this country
are properly screened and checked we got
a leaflet as we landed however
that was all in english she wasn't in
chinese the growing number of cases in
china
was a worrying development while there
is an increased likelihood
that cases may arise in this country we
are well prepared
and well equipped to deal with them
britons with families in china knew to
take precautions
they would remember the sars outbreak
from nearly 20 years ago
that disease was more deadly but covert
19
was more easily transmitted i think the
best we can do is just protect ourselves
and trying to not
get contact to everybody out there not a
lot of people are aware of the disease
right now so i think that's going to be
an issue
so sometimes
[Music]
leaving british nationals living there
uncertain about what would happen to
them
my family's so worried my mom you know
she's
texting me every five minutes calling me
every couple of hours i think
i speak for the majority of the british
expat community
this is a scary situation although it
would be
great if we we could be evacuated
i understand if we can't be the
quarantines are quarantined the decision
to lock down wuhan was seen as draconian
the idea of this working in the uk was a
non-starter for some
little did they know what was to come
you could not lock down
london or lock down sheffield or
lockdown
this country doesn't permit that britons
were repatriated from wuhan
leaving one quarantine for another once
back in the uk
morning day one of quarantine we uh
spent almost 40 hours
on the road traveling from wuhan to the
world
the risk to the uk was seen as low until
the number of cases increased
significantly
around the world
[Music]
i'm declaring a public health emergency
of international concern
over the global outbreak of novel
coronavirus we're worried that if the
chinese authorities cannot get on top of
this
in the next few weeks we may get to a
situation where this begins to spread
around the world
in a quite major way breaking news
related then
news the virus reached the uk it has
been confirmed that there are two
cases now in england two members of the
same family were the first to have
tested positive for the disease in the
uk
one of them a student at the university
of york there would be cases in
every nation of the united kingdom in
five weeks time
chinese scientists published the genetic
code of the virus online in early
january
this helped the uk to become one of the
first countries to develop a test to
identify covet 19
and it also meant work on a vaccine
could start straight away
so there are a number of different
groups racing to try and develop a
vaccine
but what we need is someone to get there
quick
the government stressed that their
actions would be dictated by the science
and the science was telling them
initially at least that mass testing
wasn't effective this was counter to who
advice
we have a simple message for all
countries
test test test
so testing of people who do not have
symptoms
is not reliable and so we won't be doing
it
questions about the uk's testing
strategy would dog
matt hancock for the rest of the year
okay
well this is our cabin some britons
found themselves in quarantine while on
holiday
as the virus spread around the world and
this is it
this has been our home for nine days
so we're all getting a bit i don't know
the diamond princess cruise ship was
sailing with more than 3 700 people on
board
when a case was detected
the passengers were quarantined but not
the staff
the crew couldn't cope with he
remembered the poor crew there same same
boat as
and that's they're expected to walk
around with a mask on
cabinets a cabin to cabin to cabinet
cabin
yeah that's actually quarantined for you
more than 700 people on board the ship
contracted the disease we have felt
relatively healthy throughout apart from
the day
i was admitted to that first hospital i
didn't realize i was
so unwell a british passenger would
become the uk's
first victim we're receiving reports
from japanese media
that a british passenger who was aboard
the diamond princess
cruise ship has now died boris johnson
chaired his first cobra meeting
his main message was wash your hands
with soap and water
whilst singing happy birthday twice
or you could use hand sanitizer if you
were lucky enough to find any
supermarket shelves were emptied of not
only sanitizer but
loo rolls and dried and fresh food
i'm a critical care nurse i've just
finished 48 hours of work
there's no fruit there's no vegetables
you just need to stop it because there's
people like me they're gonna be looking
after you
when you're at your lowest and just stop
it
fears of a national lockdown led people
to panic by
and shops to ration purchases the
coronavirus does worry me
a lot i mean it's a terrifying thing but
i cannot predict what's going to happen
what i can predict is how people
act when they're panicked so i started
picking up a few extra tins here and
there
the general population started wondering
what was going on
do i need to be wearing a mask or gloves
or sanitizing or you know we should have
this information available to us in the
space of kind of a week or two it's gone
from
something in china that doesn't really
directly affect us
to really affecting us so it's it's kind
of
scary and sobering really
chinese and south asian people were
being targeted
at least 267 hate crimes were recorded
in the first
three months of the year we were
literally just sat at the traffic lights
and he started just giving me all of
this abuse and he was threatening to
come and
basically just put me in hospital a
student from ucl
attacked on oxford street it's
ridiculous
you know it did not come from chinese
food
it came from it's a zoonotic disease
coming up next we will be live in
downing street
inside that door for the prime
minister's news conference
on the battle plan for covet 19.
boris johnson announced the government's
four-part plan
containing the virus delaying its spread
researching its origins and cure and
finally
mitigating the impact should the virus
become
more widespread let me be absolutely
clear that for the
overwhelming majority of people who
contract
the virus this will be a mild disease
from which they will speedily and fully
recover as we've already seen
yep you have we were told the nhs was
prepared for the job ahead but some
clinicians had
questions on how it would work at a
local level
how they're going to make the decisions
as to which patients to admit to
intensive care
and which patients won't get onto
intensive care how those difficult
decisions are going to be made
and who's going to be making them on
march the 5th reports emerged about
the first death in the uk a patient
with underlying health conditions has
died after testing positive
for coronavirus some people grew more
concerned about the pandemic while
others thought it was overhyped
thousands attended the cheltenham
festival but the rugby
and football seasons were suspended the
government's chief scientific advisor
had told us herd immunity was the way
forward
with sixty percent of us needing to get
the disease that's
40 million people so we want to suppress
it
not get rid of it completely which you
can't do anyway
and also allow enough of us who
are going to get mild illness to become
immune to this
to help with the sort of whole
population response
which would protect everybody that was
apparently the wrong answer
no we're very clear that herd immunity
is not part of our plan
and it's a scientific concept it is not
a goal or a
strategy over the coming days we would
see how the government's
strategy would play out
life as we knew it was about to change
the challenge ahead was to protect our
lives while protecting
our future
we were three months into the year with
spring on the horizon
when everything changed
on monday march the 16th over six
thousand people had died
worldwide 55 of them british there was
panic buying in the shops
travel restrictions were in place and
the streets were quiet
then now is the time for everyone
to stop non-essential contact with
others
stop all unnecessary travel start
working from home
where they possibly can after schools
shut their gates from friday afternoon
they will remain closed for most pupils
for the vast majority of pupils
until further notice we are collectively
telling
telling cafes pubs bars and restaurants
to close tonight and
not to open tomorrow
it was pretty clear what was coming next
from this evening i must give the
british people a very simple
instruction you must stay at home
[Music]
the measures were being put in place to
lower the rate of infection
and protect the national health service
from being overwhelmed
but there were issues hospitals and care
homes were running out of personal
protective equipment
or ppe government supplied face masks
were out of date but apparently fine to
use
and equipment recommended by the world
health organization was different
than what was being given to nhs staff
this is something that
is causing a lot of frustration among
doctors nurses health care professionals
in general
we don't feel we are getting the correct
equipment as you know we're being
responded in for a
potential coronavirus patient it would
be the frontline workers in the health
service that would be most at risk
during the pandemic and they would need
protection
we have turned around an incredibly
difficult
situation when demand for ppe shot up we
now have
good ppe supplies to all sectors
[Music]
mathematical modelling showed the uk was
about a fortnight behind
italy and cases there were spiking
maybe at the beginning we didn't know
exactly what would be happened but now
we know what happened it's you you don't
think that
it's happening here and it can't happen
everywhere else
and it happened here so i have a 59 year
old gentleman
nhs staff faced what may be some of the
most challenging moments
of their careers they went to work
when we were told to stay home and put
themselves at risk
to take care of the sick and dying which
included many of their own co-workers
we're not used to treating other health
care professionals really because
we're in the working age and we we're
still
fit and well but um
i know i i struggled with these ones
i mean there really isn't anything more
more so destroying than
having to treat a colleague
[Music]
my father would not be afraid to point
out what was wrong
because he cared about the people he
cared about his co-workers his
colleagues his family
he cared about people he had never even
met he was loved by so many it just
makes me heartbroken to see him go but
it made me so happy that i got to know
him
he did not have energy left on that day
and
that was first thing in the morning and
i thought no this is not right because
my instinct told me that this is not
this is not right something not right
and i call the ambulance
he just went out in his slippers
i didn't know he's never gonna come back
we said goodbye to him not knowing that
that would be the last time we'd see him
and after that from sunday evening to
tuesday morning he just deteriorated
body shut down organ failure
those in black and minority ethnic
communities were most at risk
of dying with the disease black lives
matter
and it as do those of
the poorest areas of our country which
have
worse health outcomes and we need to
make sure that
all of these considerations are taken
into account and action is taken
to level up the health outcomes of
people across this country
some families lost more than one loved
one to the disease
a mummy's going to be with nanny and
sorry
and um he said well i said
she's gone my nanny mate and he just he
came over
gave me a hug he had a little cry
in the afternoon he said um
he said who's next daddy is it going to
be you
or is it going to be me i said i hope
it's none of us
i said we don't want anymore to be said
no
the situation was dire in care homes as
infections ran rampant
the government delayed its pledge from
the summer to regularly test
staff and residents it's just so sad
that we've not been able to give him a
hug
we've not been able to say a proper
goodbye to him
we sat there at home just wanting to be
here and
it's sad that the first time that i am
here is after he's gone
most of us who catch the virus will have
minor symptoms but for some
surviving covert 19 means fighting for
your every breath
there's a misconception that coronavirus
is
a flu or a cold it is not
i'm sure that this has almost killed me
i'm telling you now you need your lungs
and please none of you
take any chances i mean it
because if it gets really bad
then you're gonna end up here
at one point three thousand patients a
day were being admitted to uk hospitals
and the virus was running through
care homes up and down the country the
sacrifices being made by the nhs
were recognized by the nation
[Applause]
the prime minister clapped with the
nation to show his appreciation for the
nhs
he would soon find out first hand what
an amazing job they do
when he develops symptoms i've taken a
test
that has come out positive so i am
working from home i'm self-isolating the
prime minister was sent to the hospital
when his condition deteriorated he was
there for a week
and spent three nights receiving oxygen
in intensive care
david hunt woke up in the same unit as
boris johnson
intensive care is not a fun place you
know to be
you see people die
it's absolutely horrible i sell software
for a living right
i'm not a nurse or a doctor
and you see people just getting wielded
out wielded in
um i just wanted to get out of that
place
boris johnson went to checkers to
recover for a fortnight
before getting back to work but the
majority of us
wouldn't be going back into the office
for some time
the country was asked to stay at home
and that meant shops wouldn't be opening
employees wouldn't be working and
customers wouldn't be buying
we already said goodbye to our social
life and now
it could be goodbye to our jobs too we
are seeing an absolute cliff edge here
in terms of the impacts
on the airline sector and we need to do
everything we possibly can to protect
this sector
and protect airlines the registral terms
that i've been speaking to over the past
24 hours
have suddenly gone we need to start
planning our worst case scenario which
for most of them is going
how long can we keep our restaurant shut
for and how long can we keep paying
bills while our restaurants are shut
chancellor rishi sunak's plan to stave
off economic disaster
meant he had to break all the rules
today i can announce that for the first
time
in our history the government is going
to step in
and help to pay people's wages
government grants will cover 80 percent
of the salary of retained workers
up to a total of 2 500 pounds a month
[Music]
and then we were all going to get
through this and it's great to hear what
the government
are saying that they're going to support
us which has actually taken a load off
my shoulders because i thought
you know i could lose everything you
know i could 28 years of being in
business
retail hospitality and aviation have
become the biggest losers during the
pandemic
if we don't have people in the
restaurant there's not an income
there's no money to pay the staff or for
them
if they don't earn an income they cannot
go shopping for food
they cannot pay their rent they might be
out of their houses
we've just lost our major source of
income we
will one way other reduce the amount of
income for
artists for freelance you know front of
house team our bar team our technical
team
um never minding artists on stage and
backstage
and yeah essentially jeopardize the
future of the organization additional
measures were announced by the
chancellor in an effort to shore up the
economy but
thousands of jobs have already been lost
twelve thousand jobs at british airways
and thirty five hundred positions at
virgin atlantic
travel bans and closed borders helped
bring an end to flybe
which was already in trouble before the
lockdown
a lot of us have done this job straight
out of college
from the 1819 so we're not pretty sure
we're going to do that
so the lack of footfall around city
centers has also led to difficult times
for retail shops debenhams is going out
of business putting
12 000 jobs at risk 13 000 jobs may go
at arcadia
the owner of topshop unemployment is
expected to rise to 2.6 million by the
middle of next year
applying for jobs in this climate hasn't
been easy
it's more depressing when you apply for
a role and you
obviously apply online now and then you
hear nothing
that's that that's that's more
depressing than being told
sorry you haven't got the right skill
set one employer was inundated with
applications
for 10 jobs i expected a few hundred not
fifteen thousand
so it's it's it's gratifying and
worrying at the same time
it's i would love to employ them all
employers
had to change their way of working so we
started to encourage people who could
work from home to do that and equip them
to do that and we did that
right at the beginning of march there
were plenty of people happy to give up
the morning commute
for meetings online i've got a better
work-life balance
i'm not having to wait for delayed or
cancel northern rail trains
and i know that as soon as i get out of
bed i can
log on to my laptop and not be late for
work so i've quite enjoyed working from
home
i think there's a real sort of mixed
chat about people wanting to come back
in
people wanting to work from home i think
there's a there's a big market for
coming into the office and for people
coming to the office because i think
people want to socialize get the music
on
technology allowed us to maintain some
semblance of a social life
even through the lockdown people were
finding creative ways to make
connections
and keep in touch with their communities
but for some battling loneliness would
be the biggest
challenge
it's like everything's just gone mad and
it kind of feels like a zombie
apocalypse
like there's barely any on the street
and stuff like that it's hard to
like comprehend i had five years of
school just leading up to one thing
so for it not to happen and i had like
plans and stuff like that even for
results day
and it just like can't happen anymore
every day like you're just improvising
you don't really know what you're doing
a few weeks ago i was there
had my books out i had a countdown on my
phone saying 73 days left to your exam
start
and now i'm just playing fifa at my
house just not really doing much
millions of students were forced out of
the classroom during the spring lockdown
the exams they spent years studying for
cancelled it was weird because like
normally when you set an exam you'll
know if you've done
like okay or if you've done bad but
because you didn't know like you
don't know what it could have been like
i think it's the idea that we didn't
really know like how your results would
be because you didn't set the exam so i
don't know i was like
um but like i'm happy with the results
so it's been okay i think
i love my place at medical school
instead of exams a-level students were
given grades based on an
algorithm in some cases the results
varied greatly from their predicted
grades
we thought oh maybe they will do them in
a different way maybe they'll move them
a little back or or something around
that but for them to just say oh no
exams are cancelled it's just it's just
kind of like a slap on their face really
around 280 000 students had their
results downgraded i got
an abb i was predicting an ace iaa i'm
trying to get into medicine so sadly
with the grades that i've received i
can't go anywhere
it's important to admit that mistake
then move on and try and make a better
appeals process
and possibly just take us back to our
center that's crazy our teachers have
known us for years
they know what we're capable of
[Applause]
boris johnson had called the system
robust and dependable
but the government eventually made a
u-turn the idea that this problem has
somehow come up and bit me on the back
side
it is nonsense education secretary gavin
williamson
was accused of acting too late but says
every stage
both for dfe and off qual in terms of
the development of a moderated grade
system
have actually put the issue of making
sure that children from the most
disadvantaged backgrounds are at the
heart of what it does
life wasn't that simple for the younger
students either as parents took over the
reins as teachers
it was a problem faced the world over
here
i'm quite sad that um my friends can't
really be with me because of the
coronavirus
but it's nice seeing um how my mum and
dad teach me
and i can teach my brother some things
i think there's going to be challenges
where we have to all cut ourselves some
slack and just do the very best
that we can i know that there's going to
be beautiful moments
and really challenging moments and
that's okay we all tried to make the
best of it with tablets
laptops desktop computers and
smartphones how are you doing
i'm good the kids were literally left to
their
own devices good thing is that i'll
still have an education
but it's just going to be at home and
most of my clubs now
have been made um so it's going to be
online like my piano class is going to
be facetime
and um a club create a device that's
going to be
on google classroom though not every
family
has access to digital
juggle it devices all the children we
normally start with the youngest
try and do hair first and then go all
the way up and
just squeeze it all in through the day
but also we can't get it all done in one
go because
we have to share the laptop so it can
take quite a while
maths and english weren't the only
subjects on the timetable there was
music
from marlene class
and pe with joe wicks so every single
day next week from monday to friday
at 9am i'm going to be the nation's pe
teacher
the 2020 student experience was anything
but normal
this is my bed i've been spending most
of my time now
university students returned to campus
for online lectures and
some socially distanced fun but the
numbers have covered positive cases
amongst students grew because obviously
all of us got symptoms as well and we
all tested positive but
it was quite reassuring to have everyone
else with you as well
so we weren't alone we weren't having to
like you know be stuck in our own rooms
it's horrible because you can't even
really like
i can't go outside at all and i've
obviously had to tell my flatmates to
isolate which was after only knowing
them
for like a week it wasn't like the
greatest conversation
young people felt they were being blamed
for starting a second wave of the virus
social distancing self-isolation and a
reduction of face-to-face lectures was
having an impact
we've seen lots of students saying that
they're spending all or most of their
time within their university
accommodation
and clearly that kind of risks feelings
of isolation or loneliness and that
combined with
worse and mental health is definitely
going to be a challenge
throughout the pandemic there have been
fears for the nation's mental health
many of us have struggled with
loneliness depression and general
anxiety
because of covert i'm a little
disappointed with
some people some friends that i've not
heard from
anywhere near as much as i expected to
the feeling i've
have now or have had more over in the
last six months
is just of being very numb to everything
um feeling like i can't i can't
get a reaction out of myself for
anything most of us
feel that somehow if we're lonely it's
our fault and we are a bit ashamed of it
and don't want to talk
about it but i think we can all think
about
is there somebody today who might be
lonely
who you could ring up and just tell them
that you know you were thinking about
[Music]
them
communities did manage to come together
during lockdown
to have a little dance in the street
[Music]
a socially distanced marathon
or a charity walk around the garden
[Music]
living under lockdown was not an easy
thing to do
so some people were a little upset when
news emerged that boris johnson's
closest advisor had driven
with his wife and young son from london
to durham
and took his family to barnard castle
his wife had coveted symptoms when they
made the journey
mr cummings developed symptoms later on
i
knew what the guidance was
it talks about exceptional circumstances
with with small children
and i think that in all the
circumstances i behave reasonably
illegally as i
uh as i said my opinion is that if i had
a four-year-old son
in the situation he was in i wouldn't
have hesitated to do
exactly the same thing
sorry i was i'm speechless with him
he's disgusting and she should step down
before he's asked
to leave a lot of people have done the
same thing
it's not like it's an uncommon thing but
obviously him being a figure that he is
so i think that it's up to the
government
so but it would be nice for him to
resign i think it's taking the
the public for a fall dominic cummings
did leave downing street but much later
and over a different crisis
[Music]
after nearly two months under lockdown
boris johnson announced there was a plan
underway to ease some of the
restrictions
there would be a gradual reopening of
society if certain conditions were met
which would decrease the number of
deaths and minimize risk
to the nhs we have a route and we have a
plan
and everyone in government has the
all-consuming pressure and challenge
to save lives restore livelihoods and
gradually
restore the freedoms that we need the
prime minister replaced
stay at home with stay alert and
encourage people back to work if they
couldn't work from home
wales scotland and northern ireland were
not going to follow
england's lead for scotland right now
given the fragility
of the progress we've made given the
critical
point that we are at then it would be
catastrophic for me to drop the
stay-at-home message which is why i am
not prepared
to do it and i'm particularly not
prepared to do it
in favor of a message that is vague and
imprecise
the message i will be giving to people
in wales is is while they must be alert
to the continuing danger of coronavirus
if you're not out of
your house for an essential purpose and
that does include exercise it can
include shopping and it can
must include going to work for people
who can safely do so
staying at home remains the best way
that you can protect yourself and others
lockdown restrictions for england were
eased on the 13th of may with people
getting their first taste of freedom for
weeks
over time we saw a further lifting of
the restrictions
shops began to open there was unlimited
exercise two more steps to go said hugh
and some primary school students went
back into the classroom
but we needed to keep an eye on the
numbers we are
i would say through the current peak we
need to be worried
uh as a nation um that as we come
through this current
peak we do not uh seed another one
the lockdown seemed like a distant
memory by the time summer came around
families planned quarantine-free
holidays and people were eating out to
help out
it was a battle to save the health of
the economy
[Music]
gradually restrictions were eased and
summer holidays were back
on spain opened its borders to britons
in june
tourists could stay without having to
quarantine upon
arrival as long as we all take our own
protection and take
responsibility for ourselves and
everybody else we should be all right
it was a blessing for those who were
left disappointed from cancelled trips
earlier in the year
we thought we weren't getting married we
were just going to do something in the
uk and now we'll be able to go back it's
absolutely fantastic
we do have flights booked hotels booked
everything
we'd obviously postponed them once
already so it's been quite a stressful
time for us
it was a far cry from the thousands of
passengers who normally head out
for some spanish sun
the customer confidence is it is down
do people want to be on an airplane at
this present moment in time
going through the securities in airports
etcetera etcetera so i can understand
why
people are a little bit apprehensive
air bridges were set up to help the
travel industry recover
and allow uk residents a well-earned
break after lockdown
without having to quarantine after they
returned
so announces so excited to go now
yeah it's like a freedom i was
thinking that there was a good chance
i'd have to self-isolate when i came
back
i work from home so it's not the end of
the world but it would have been a bit
of a drag going back home to see my
family with with my baby
i haven't been there since december and
after
this log down i'm really looking forward
to seeing them
holidaymakers were seduced by the sun
and sand
but some regions of spain were seeing a
growing number of cases
the government decided to close the
spanish travel corridor and ask anyone
returning from the country
to quarantine for 14 days we've got a
small hotel here
five rooms and that um proportion
like proportionally speaking lots of
them are counselling so that's because
people might not immediately think to
cancel our restaurant reservation
because it's part of
other things they booked for the holiday
they'll deal with their flights first
their hotel the hotel rooms are dropping
like flies
five days ago it would have been fine
five days later it's not
one day later even and yeah one day you
can and one day you can't
i'm afraid you are starting to see in
some places the signs
of a second wave of the pandemic when
people are coming back
from abroad if they're coming back from
a place where i'm afraid there is
another outbreak they must go into into
quarantine and
that's why we've taken uh the action
that we have and we will continue
uh throughout the summer to take such
action where
it is necessary a rise in the number of
infections meant it soon became
necessary for france
we cross over yesterday literally 24
hours ago
drove quickly down south and then last
night we
realized that the quarantine had come
back come in
so we quickly went online booked a spot
on the euro tunnel and
drove back it should be a full
quarantine or no quarantine it seems to
be
the changing isn't helping the economy
it's not up in people's travel plans
um so it's just confusing everyone to be
honest with you
i think everyone just wants clarity
british tourists
rushed to the border to make it back
before the deadline when people travel
at the moment when coronavirus is still
a thing
just need to be aware that unfortunately
um things can change very quickly
and you know if you go with your eyes
open you know that things
can change it won't then come as so much
of a surprise
a staycation was an option for those not
wanting to risk a quarantine
well we've been looking at cottages
there's places where we can have a
little staycation and i think because
we've left it quite late
and everyone is doing the same thing
it's proving really hard to find a place
where all five of us can go
uk beaches were full on sunny days and
campsites were even busy
on the rainy ones we have some great fun
the kids love it
kids are happy as long as kids are happy
where you happy
[Music]
the summer season brought a much needed
boost to the uk economy
the chancellor's eat out to help out
scheme in august
helped sell more than a hundred million
meals according to the treasury
busy weekend and also monday to
wednesday uh wednesday just gone was our
the most reservations we ever had in one
day uh since we opened seven years ago
the government's scientific advisors
though were concerned there was
too much socializing and not enough
social distancing
people have relaxed too much and um now
is the time
for us to re-engage and realize that
this
is a continuing threat to us
[Music]
by autumn there was a divergence among
the four nations on how to control the
virus
communities on either side of a national
border faced different restrictions
and local lockdowns
there were disagreements about messaging
and measures but
all agreed a vaccine was urgently needed
[Music]
each single project does not have a high
probability of success
so although everyone goes out with great
enthusiasm and we hope they work
it's never the case that you know you've
got a vaccine that's going to work
this is going to come from somewhere we
just need to back
lots of horses at the moment and to make
sure we're in a great position
to access a vaccine when it occurs a
breakthrough came in november when
interim results were announced for one
of the vaccine candidates
the pfizer bioentech vaccine has been
tested on over 40
000 volunteers and interim results
suggest
it is proving 90 effective at protecting
people
against the virus
it's not about a single winner and
everybody else is losers
we need as many vaccine candidates as
possible for a number of reasons first
of all
we have interim data from the visa
vaccine we don't know how long it will
give an immune response
so the more candidates we have the
better the toolbox is
and the more vaccines in general we have
that can be rolled out
whether it's to the uk population or
globally
so we need as many candidates to
actually get past the finishing line
in early december the uk became the
first country in the world to approve
the pfizer biontech vaccine for use
nearly a year since the virus entered
our lives
this recommendation has only been given
following the most
rigorous scientific assessment of every
piece
of data so that it meets the required
strict standards of safety of
effectiveness
and of quality the uk pre-ordered
40 million single doses and once you
allow for wastage
that's enough to vaccinate around 18
million people
ninety-year-old margaret keenan made
history as the first person in the world
to receive the jab now i've done it and
hopefully it'll help other people come
along
and do as i did you know try and
try and do the best for to get rid of
this terrible thing
the national rollout had begun i felt
proud and
emotional we've worked very hard and to
get to this point and
um the health service in general and has
struggled throughout the fight
and for covert 19 so it feels like a
momentous day i said oh it's just been
nerve-wracking today i really lost for
words this morning um
but um yeah i didn't think it'd be
possible this year
it's the first time my major vaccine has
come through
so quickly so to be part of that
is amazing some critics are concerned
that the years of research and
development
usually needed to produce a vaccine has
been condensed
to just a few months and i just implore
people to
to think really hard and just to do it
for all the right reasons
they are going to be doubters but i
think we should do it
we should do it the vaccine won't be a
silver bullet
i think we don't know yet exactly how uh
good that all the vaccines are going to
be at preventing the transmission of the
virus we know they're good at stopping
people getting symptomatic disease
and we know they're good at protecting
people from severe disease we need to
understand how good they are also at
stopping transmission between people and
that information will come over the next
few months
it will gradually make a huge huge
difference
but i stress gradually because you know
we're not
there yet we haven't defeated this virus
yet
scientists became concerned about a
mutant strain of the coronavirus
we have identified a new variant of
coronavirus
which may be associated with the faster
spread in the southeast of england
initial analysis suggests that this
variant is growing faster than the
existing variants
viruses mutate all the time but
according to the government's scientific
advisors
this variant was more transmissible but
there was nothing to suggest
it was more deadly boris johnson took
action
with new restrictions for london and the
south east of england
residents in those areas must stay at
home
non-essential retail indoor gyms and
leisure facilities and
personal care services must close
people must work from home if they can
in england
those living in tier four areas should
not mix with anyone outside
their own household at christmas
across the rest of the country the
christmas rules allowing up to three
households to meet
will now be limited to christmas day
only
rather than the five days as previously
set out
news about the variant prompted several
european countries to close their
borders to the uk
hundreds of trucks were backed up on the
motorway waiting to enter france
and uk travelers were banned from at
least 40 countries
it was like deja vu travel restrictions
closed shops and government requests to
stay
at home it doesn't really feel like
christmas feels really miserable i think
if it weren't for the kids we probably
wouldn't even put the tree up
it's a bit hard but you just have to try
and crack on with it
it is really hard but what can you do
worrying isn't going to change it is it
so i'll just
move forward instead of in the same
place i don't want to live in this
kind of world with people passing their
way and everything it's just
heartbreaking
coronavirus changed everything for us in
2020
from the way we live and work to the way
we socialize with friends and educate
our children
we relied on experts in science and
medicine
and we were asked to accept rules that
limited our freedom
the old stresses of day-to-day life were
replaced
by new worries about the future
we lived through nearly a year of covert
19
but we may be feeling its impact for
several years to come
you